what's up with a minute it's your boy
watts homie quan and you are now tuned
in to the bootleg calf podcast check it
out esau though
like all right [ __ ] i i i'll probably
wear like uh snoop dogg redid the
chronic hat i'll wear that we gotta do a
ranking of like the worst
hip-hop clothing lines of all time
that's funny that'd be good shady ltd
snoop dogg clothing
yums
oh yums is bad like oh my god that is
horrible dude that and truck fit i just
hate the designs i thought truck fit was
cringy bad yeah like yeah like they paid
me money are we recording i just started
recording
all right
okay well listen we have watomi quan in
the building what's happening with
standing we're going to start the show
off ranking the worst hip hop closing
lines of all time
right let's go let's go
the candidates
last kings
truck fit
yums
shady ltd
snoop dogg clothing okay
outcast clothing
oh
damn um i think those are probably
are we forgetting any any candidates
i think we're forgetting babe
ice cream bbc no babes those are i mean
people still wear that that's that's
that's good stuff because cause you said
it great to watch i didn't know i mean
the worst oh the world was talking about
shitty shitty ones oh [ __ ] um
i think soulja boy [ __ ] was the worst
yums yeah so we're gonna go yums is
number one yeah truck fit truck fit
number two number two well truck fit i
was a truck fit dj
and so they would pay me like 500 a
month
to like that they'd send me a box of
clothes yeah
and i would always take a picture
holding the shirt up
and post it
i'm saying check out my boys
all my homies were just wearing truck
fit because they didn't give a [ __ ] but
i'm like yo he's on record talking about
sucking dick for truck fishing like
don't question how i got my truck fit so
yeah i'm good on this like wayne kind of
shot himself in the foot yeah um and it
just was
hideous yeah it it it was so truck fit
snoop dogg clothing and i love snoop
yeah
doggy style is my second favorite album
of all time the album that changed my
life yeah but snoop dogg clothing mm-hmm
was it bad to you
it was really bad well what about the
[ __ ] in the 90s i like the sum of the
jerseys because my my popsie had a few
hockey jerseys
no limit clothing oh [ __ ]
no limit ah
master p loki you know if you had the
master p kicks yeah or you had the
camouflage jersey you was one of them
you was one of them yeah
yeah you was that guy so it's like it
was good bad it was a good bad bad
snoop dogg clothing i always thought was
like
man a 50 year old [ __ ] would love this
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
me being like a 17 year old white kid
i'm like i don't know where i'm supposed
to where they see it i don't know what
i'm supposed to do with this yeah yeah i
don't got no enemies i don't got nobody
to bang on so i'm not gonna wear this
i'm gonna say the number three worst
clothing line was eminem's clothesline
though shady ltd yeah yeah um i will
wear some g units and like that's it
had some [ __ ] yeah i would have never
forgotten the clothing was away because
it was like an extension of echo yeah
and then okay remember game had um
game had some [ __ ] too didn't he
yeah
some shoes oh it ain't closed hurricanes
yeah the hurricanes yeah that's the name
of them [ __ ] hurricanes but
uh
you said fat form and what else no i
never was a fat farmer oh platform wave
yeah okay fat forward i think eminem
[ __ ] was like yeah if you were wearing
that like
you probably drank mountain dew and like
your uncle
who who wears a wife beater and smokes
lives at home in a trailer they may or
may not have molested you as a child oh
yeah so you're like you know i'm gonna
go to macy's and buy some [ __ ] shady
ltd
i'm not even gonna buy it i'm gonna
steal it because i can't afford it
because i want to dress like eminem
okay who the [ __ ] wakes up and says let
me dress like eminem um suburban baggy
sweatsuits
shady ltd do rag that was white like yo
like yeah remember when eminem was
wearing durags yeah
bad bad
very bad i bet you eminem looks back on
his fashion choices and he's like dude
what the [ __ ] what are you doing man
fight drugs those pills [ __ ] up my
judgment
sorry em i love you and then are we
gonna do last kings is the fifth worst
oh yeah last kings was bad
you know last kings i i just never could
come to the
like as a grown-up in the world
like i'm gonna wear tiger's clothes yeah
but there was people wearing it yeah
yeah it was people wearing that [ __ ]
like it means [ __ ] had side effects
they could just wear their clothes and
be talking
like yeah bro i like going to the mall
like just
just saying tiger [ __ ] when you wear the
clothes that's why i wasn't wearing it
so the top five worst are we we're gonna
go yums
we're gonna go
truck fit truck fit
eminem mm-hmm
snoop dogg clothing
oh gee snoop dogg
oh
yeah the the other side shouldn't you go
to burlington and it'd be there for like
11 years like the [ __ ] suits i like the
jerseys though
um and then
and then last kings yeah last kings yeah
cause at least like the last kings i
think some people wore last kings yeah
some people did my [ __ ] trail king
trail he used to wear that [ __ ] for a
couple minutes but i wasn't wearing it
didn't he own it yeah
[Music]
oh so you had to okay so nevermind you
had to okay yeah he owned the clothing
line
i hope he [ __ ] wore it
jesus christ they had that story out
fairfax that nobody would you oh oh my
god
i'm damn i would drive by that [ __ ] i'm
like yo that's a holy [ __ ]
tiger would have to just pull up though
you know what i mean people would come
yeah [ __ ] gonna slide shout out to
tiger man uh anyway welcome to the show
tommy kwan yes sir for people who don't
know who you are what you do man
um
give us a breakdown
all right basically why somebody should
i be looking at anything yeah no just
look at me watch homie quan yeah yeah um
comedian from watts california um i do
hood type of comedy uh i bring a sense
of
authentic
goodness if that's even a word
um i tell her stories in uh in an in an
authentic way and provide people from
the hood opportunities to
get a chance at being a part of
hollywood and doing films and stuff and
you started as an artist right yeah i
was doing music and stuff first so what
um
you're you know it's obviously a hard
industry to make it in as an artist what
what made you kind of pivot and go more
full in on the content and the comedy um
it was a video one day like when
instagram first started new videos when
they first started doing videos it was
15 seconds um i was just like just on
some funny [ __ ] i was like uh this is
how gang members dance at a party and it
was me doing a dance called the hoop
stump i did that it went viral and then
um the father started coming in so i was
like oh i always wanted to get into
acting so this might be that avenue so i
started doing that and then once i
started doing the comedy stuff because
my personality and who i am is just
goofy so
um started doing that [ __ ] and then it
just blew up so then when i started to
try to put out music it was hard for the
newer fans to gravitate to it because
they're like oh you comedy right right
right so i started doing uh celebrity
impressions so they can still hear my
bars but here from a different person
they'll be like oh this [ __ ] hard so
the acting [ __ ] just it just blew up so
the music kind of fell in the background
um
i think it's dope because like like you
said like what you do i think is very is
authentic but it's also kind of like
for anybody who's not from l.a it's also
like low-key educational yeah yeah i'm
like the hood
um learner's guide i am
the hood pass if you will yeah i feel
like you kind of like touch on so many
like
things that nobody would even think
about if they because you know we live
in l.a yeah
most people ain't from here who who are
within this industry this music industry
this entertainment industry a lot of
transplants but a lot of people like
don't really know how to move around out
here for me my hood pass was dj head
west coast dj head kind of had to put me
on the hey look don't wear this hat yeah
just
dj i remember one night at the radio
station head broke down
every gang beef in la because i had no
[ __ ] idea that this gang beats with
this gang and there's a reason why
you'll never hear this artist work with
this artist and
and i was just like oh [ __ ] the politics
it's crazy i always knew there was
politics but i didn't know that like
you know
[ __ ] sets beef with crips at some places
i'm just like what the [ __ ] is going on
so um but i feel like you kind of like
are like a very like
easily digestible way of like kind of
just understanding la culture a bit more
thank you i appreciate that yeah did you
was that kind of like the goal for you
to kind of because you know
people always think hollywood and the
valley is la but it's not it's not it's
not at all um was that your kind of goal
though like i want to be funny but i
also want to make sure like i kind of
shine a light on like the culture of the
city yeah um honestly bro
um
i wanted to
be a voice for people
that come from where i come from because
we don't really have a voice too much we
had a voice with john singleton ice cube
dj pool rest in peace uh
uh f gary gray
uh you know um filmmakers like that and
um
those movies were so dope they told our
story but it still needed to be dug in a
little deeper so what i always valued
was just us i love who we are so i was
like
okay and all these movies and all these
films they have people from other places
portraying us why aren't we portraying
us so i'm like all right i'ma provide
these opportunities for people that look
like me that come from where i come from
these opportunities to show them
we capable of doing this doing this [ __ ]
too so
i just took pride in like us like i love
us so much so i'm a show i'm gonna show
the fun side i'ma show the ignorance i'm
gonna show everything i'ma put
everything in in the video and that
gives you whatever like thought proc
like whatever thoughts you get off of
the video i'll leave it open for you to
discuss whatever you want but i'm
showing everything as a whole to get you
to laugh get you to heal through the
pain but also to see the ignorance that
we continue to put out to show you like
look at yourself
yeah and then you also kind of just like
you said you bring in people from from
la like you know you'll collaborate with
juno or like certain people who are who
are
you know you'll share your platform
right with other la personalities so i
think that's dope man thank you um talk
about growing up in la which is like for
people who don't know it's like a tv
show that you that you're behind that
um
it skits it's uh
how many episodes did you do i did five
this season five um self-produced yeah
yeah so uh give us like a rundown of
growing up in la because that's on your
youtube channel right yes on my youtube
channel um growing up in la is the
scarce comedy show uh i created um with
the help of
um my lady mike williams she um she
helped me um
figure out the concept and basically um
i wanted to do a sketch show like
all my life about my experience of
growing up in la but also tying the
things that
inspired me as a kid right so she was
like okay boom we're gonna get together
look just how you write this so i
structured it and um i do skits where it
consists of me sitting on the couch
looking at tv and i'm reenacting the
[ __ ] on tv like cops cheaters [ __ ] like
that and it's just a variety sketch so
like all the [ __ ] i watched um robert
townsend's um
uh uh um what was the name of the show
robert townsend's uh uh uh uh uh uh uh
partners in crime um the day chappelle
show the wayne's brother jamie foxx show
martin all that so i i incorporated all
those things into this sketch show which
allowed you to see the black and brown
community getting together and then you
see like these different situations and
these different characters and
it's just like something dope for the
city just really la based but you get
the hints of different spots when you
can watch certain things and they're
like oh [ __ ] that resonates with where
i'm from yeah it's also impressive
because like you know i think in 2022 or
2021 when you first put the episodes out
like you feel like
a lot of content creators
traditionally will depend on
a machine
or a
developmental deal or something to do
what you did yeah when now we have our
own plan like youtube like you know what
i'm saying like
there's really no excuse
if you got an idea
you put your head down save your money
figure it out yeah you should be able to
execute your ideas like
was it for you was it like
did you try to shop that idea around
before you just decided to put it out or
were you like let me put it out first
yeah and then garner interest and yeah
um my whole thing was i wanted to do it
myself like with the show
producing myself i written it myself i
got to cast myself everything i more so
was like i'm not waiting for nobody to
give me opportunity i'm gonna give
myself an opportunity because a lot of
times we tend to wait on other people to
throw in that life raft instead of
jumping out in the ocean and swimming
yourself and figuring it out so i was
like i'm gonna do this show my damn self
and if it blows up that way it goes that
way but with me doing it myself i'm
gonna learn the importance of
independence and figuring it out on my
own so i'm not at a cross road to if
this [ __ ] don't work i don't know how to
do this i'm gonna do this now and we're
gonna see what happens what were some of
the lessons that like because
obviously doing something for the first
time you're gonna be like okay [ __ ] yeah
uh the next season we gotta do this
different right what were some of the
things that you either made mistakes on
or that you learned from the first
season that you know bro um
hiring a better crew
like not like that like i got love for
the the the crew i did have but i feel
like they didn't execute the vision well
um and that what that was is the reason
why we only have five episodes because
it was just like a battle of power
and the thing is
bro we are here to work together i'm
saying i give you instruction you can
throw your opinions cool i will take
that and if i if i can apply it i will
apply it but if i'm writing this and i'm
doing this
like trust me in my vision and i'm
letting you know how i should go so that
um
making sure everything is taken care of
for sound and all that [ __ ] because that
[ __ ] really matters it doesn't matter
uh uh the the right little things that
you don't even think about are these
things that like yeah make your [ __ ]
look like official or makes it look like
yeah yeah so that and um
and really uh
what was another thing that i learned
from the show um
that was it just a production because
everything else was cool because it was
like all people that i worked with
before so everybody else was easy and
fun to do it but it was just
hiring the right crew the small things
really does matter especially if it's
like your first thing coming out with
that can be the
the rise or the fall of who you are
because if it's like super shitty during
the first go-around it makes people kind
of hesitant to like uh i don't want to
know right right now that's real that's
real just taking care of those small
details sound uh the color the right
editing like all that [ __ ] really
means a lot wait hold on time to stop
the interview because we got to talk
about our good folks at odd socks man
listen if you go to
oddssoxoficial.com that's odd
soxofficial.com use the keyword keyword
it's a [ __ ] promo code use the
[ __ ] promo code bootleg kev all right
at checkout you'll save 20 off they got
i mean look at these spongebob joints
man the ninja turtle boys you know what
i'm saying how about the naruto guys
and then they got the new odd socks
basics that are just like
they're just so fly man the tie-dye
joints they just listen man
whatever you need they got it how about
some half-baked boys you know what i'm
saying listen
the most comfortable socks the most
affordable socks the best socks in the
world odd socks so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use that keyword it's not a keyword it's
a [ __ ] promo code
[ __ ] bootleg cab at checkout save 20 off
man shout out to our family at odd socks
if you support us go support them um
for people who come to la uh-huh
give me a give me the uh parameters of
where the real la starts cause most
people will be in [ __ ] melrose
getting robbed these days because
they're [ __ ] walking around with
jewelry and it's it's hot out here um
but like what where's like
you know where would you suggest the
people actually tap in if they really
want to get into like actual real l.a
culture not just
melrose and fairfax you got to hit the
other side of pico like all like all the
hood spots man um
[ __ ] i say um
it's just the it's really the other side
of people i say like [ __ ] once you
cross like go to the east side and
that's basically like um
like uh you know
south central watts
um
uh like the the west side not going
towards like you know hollywood and all
this stuff that's right that's that's
the cute [ __ ] once you go to the hood to
like where you seeing full spots like
tams uh uh master burgers um
um like certain fish factories and all
that [ __ ] that's the hood [ __ ]
you
is it frustrating being a la native yeah
like i feel like it's like i'm trying to
figure out how to explain this [ __ ]
because i'm like i just feel like la is
so like i don't want to miss no parts
people come here and they
pillage
what the opportunities are that the city
gives them yeah but then they'll go on
twitter and bash la yeah like nah that's
like that [ __ ] happens so much
and he's like yo like the audacity of
[ __ ] come here like yeah get a
[ __ ] townhouse in [ __ ] woodland
hills yeah and then [ __ ] on the whole
[ __ ] on l.a yeah so you live in woodland
hills exactly you're not in the hood
part but the thing is now when you come
to this spot now you got to watch your
ass because yeah because you're over
here running everybody you can't do that
like you
have to
no in l.a you got to know how to speak
you got to know what words not to say
and different like different [ __ ] like
that it's like different words that you
could every day use can also be a dis
what are those words
i can't say none of them words okay on
camera but
it's certain
items objects like food um wait there's
food it's food names that are disses
like you gotta be careful of like yeah
you can't say crab
yeah okay see okay now that used to be
so bad but now it's kind of like
not okay but it's like you can kind of
get away with it because that's not
something that you you can expect
everybody to know like the certain said
like certain pastries and certain
juices and
certain snacks you can't say none of
that [ __ ] wow cause you get your ass
packed out crispy like i'm gonna go get
some [ __ ] legs like they don't say crabs
um
what is the safe hat to wear la
uh blue one is low key safe but like
the 18s where you know the blue la hat
um
is the 18's the mexican game yeah okay
18 yeah yes
so uh black la hat is the yeah like
that's that's like the safest joint
i'm from arizona what about a diamond
backside can i is it is the arizona
diamondbacks hat anything anywhere
i feel like you're the guy to ask
it it definitely can be
um but that's not in my opinion no
disrespect to nobody but it's not
one of the hot more high ranking hats
right like i cuz cuz i got i got a z hat
bro at the house
it's kind of like
it can be but like i can i think i'll
kind of be okay
but that it you can still get some flack
with that [ __ ] if you had a high
ranking if you had to rank uh the top
five high ranking hats in la as far as
like hey
careful where you wear these
[ __ ] oh yeah what would they be
[Music]
the i say number one
number one would be the houston astros
which is hoover's the hoover hat uh then
you have
you have the the 60s had the the uh the
mariners the s dome yep then you have
the faux glove which uh the photies had
um that's
the brewers yeah yeah
yeah
right um
uh uh uh um um um um um um
the [ __ ] um
what's the bps is the cardinals
saying louis cardinals yeah saint louis
called the stl hat how to get you [ __ ]
over
um
and
the t-hat
texas yeah the t-hat for trey gaines and
20 bloods like
you get your ass whooped on with like
with them hats on i mean ny had yeah of
course but like certain ones pinpoint
exact hoods like the 40s in in in the
60s had like like a new york hat is just
neighborhood right yes neighborhood you
get your you get your eyes whipped on
with that hat too yeah and it's crazy
because so many people just that's like
the most popular hat in the world yeah
people just be like i need a yankee
fitted yeah yeah yeah i i didn't trade
that [ __ ] in front of it
i did a skit with the homie lewis from
the bay and he was like you're like
what's up with my hat i'm like now you
can't wear that that's a neighborhood
that he like what so they gonna trip on
jay-z nah they know jay-z [ __ ] they
don't know you they [ __ ] you up
you can't wear that [ __ ]
jay-z nah jay-z smoove
um you got to like uh obviously you know
the wilding out thing is a big deal
first of all i feel like nick cannon
doesn't get enough flowers in general
just for like
wilding out and the
careers that have helped start and um
just
i look up to nick cannon i don't think
he's an incredible businessman
incredible creative but um
uh how did that initially happen um
basically uh
i was going through like a bad
relationship like i said all the time
um and i was asking god for a sign when
i got on my instagram i said they kind
of like yo boy nick kenny who y'all want
to see on water now y'all yada yada so
um i got up and i took the last money i
had went to the slauson got me a water
knife hoodie and i started doing skits
every day and um it's like the the view
started to go up on it um then people
were like i'm gonna get you i'm gonna
link you when they can and no no never
did it dj head called me like hey you
talked to nick i was like nine talk to
nick he like all right
connected the dots put nick on the phone
and nick was like hey
um
people been telling me about your [ __ ] i
just never watched it um but i can't
guarantee you're gonna make my show but
i can give you an audition and i was
like bro don't guarantee me [ __ ] give me
the audition and i'll show you why
because i don't believe in
nobody just giving me something like
that just here yeah yeah you'd rather
earn it because i want to know the
importance of
having this
versus me having it and not knowing the
importance of it you know i'm saying i i
wanna i wanna work my way to to
understand why i got this so
um they was like all right do an
audition tape
like what you mean doing audition tape
like i don't gotta come to y'all they're
like nah make your own i was like [ __ ]
went to the barber shop
set it up like the water and i had the
tables had the chairs i had the water
now girls and i played every game and i
did all that and i put in the video and
they didn't hit me back so i was like oh
my [ __ ] sucked and then they called me
like
i think like a week or so before my
birthday and i was like want to fly you
to atlanta and um you know go to
workshop and that's how that happened
cause my hard work head you know what
i'm saying ali hooping that [ __ ] because
i deserved it not cause he just doing a
favor but i deserved it and
the rest was history as i got there
being like somebody who's creating so
much dope content doing your own
independent tv show have like
any of like the hollow hollywood scene
or industry reached out to maybe have
you helped write or do any sort of
acting or anything is that
no i i've gotten some acting
opportunities um
and you know um i was able to um
low-key like i don't want to say like
that but i was able to like chat with
like issa's team she's doing um amazing
i want to like meet her i wasn't
insecure too but i didn't get a chance
to fully meet issa but um
yeah like just people just just watching
and i'm happy with them watching why
because they tuned in so whatever the
[ __ ] i do that opportunity gonna meet
itself one day yeah i love like uh just
how she curates that [ __ ] like well
obviously the show's over now but yeah
um
the music yeah it just feels suited it
is like it's so it's so
like
hood like not even in a bad way
she get the locals and then she had like
you know people from different spots too
but like just the locals she catered to
her section and it's like love yeah it
feels like um
almost like a
like a commercial version of like what
you do i guess it's like if you watch
that show when you're in houston or
something yeah you kind of get a real
taste of like la culture
and what it's like to be like a young
woman in l.a and you know what i'm
saying like yeah that's why i love issa
man even watching the uh the uh the
misinventions of awkward black girl
watching how it developed from that on
youtube
to there like she is the prime example
of getting it out the mud and chasing
your dream like
i love what easter is doing like no
excuse doing your own [ __ ] at all and
then people will find you and if they
gonna [ __ ] with you they gonna [ __ ] with
you you're just gonna keep running it up
yeah so like i love the [ __ ] out of that
man and i thank you for that compliment
too yeah how um
how has the pandemic affected you
um it affected me in a good way i was
gonna say because i feel like you you
kind of went up in the past oh yeah oh
for sure yeah for sure because
um
it leveled the playing field for all
creatives around the world
you ain't got no excuse oh they get more
attention to me [ __ ] we in the house
like so
um that's how i got my youtube popping
bro like
um the first kid i did during the
pandemic was i did a remake of i am
legend but i was doing it as the
pandemic version some of my heart is
like no toilet paper and um
i'm outside looking for gas if anybody
got that uh the gas pack hit my lawn
what do so i did that and then um i
started doing uh hella skits every day
and i ran it up on youtube i had about
like 400
youtube subscribers by the end of the
first year of the pandemic i had like
110
wow k followers wow you got that plaque
whoa yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i got
that flag i'm proud of that [ __ ]
i'm on my way to the uh the fire honey k
plaque yeah i'm saying then i'm hit that
milly i'm about to be in the game bro
that's big man yeah the thing that's
dope is like like you said like i always
tell people like the pandemic
made it to where i feel like you have no
excuse because
all of the like even if you were like a
you know my industry or your radio
personality like
like
artists were doing ig lives yeah zooms
and mm-hmm and so like it really leveled
the playing field for everybody yeah so
it really kind of to me like separated
like
who's really yeah with this [ __ ] come on
just like
really not built for this [ __ ] anyway
yeah yeah like
i i i was like all right bro look i
don't give a [ __ ]
if it don't work
i'm gonna try it at least i can say it
didn't once i tried you feel me so i was
like this pandemic we're gonna run it up
we got out filming every single day we
shoot all skits on a cell phone not even
an iphone on the um
on a on a samsung galaxy
s20 that's 20. that's the one and i edit
on my iphone so i keep both on me yeah i
mean i got my
but i got them both yeah yeah but y'all
know that galaxy that [ __ ] the
camera is bad it's fire it's fire it's
just there's just no imessage
that's the only bad part about it and
emojis are shitty yes but if the galaxy
got the imessage i think your bubbles
weren't [ __ ] great oh bye bye
bye bye
that camera fire all of your skits are
shot on a cell phone yep all on a cell
phone and edit on my uh iphone so you
don't even edit on a laptop no i did i
did with my hands wow what program do
you use um
i'm i'm i'm a tail i never really told
it but i use imovie okay uh i use inshot
and this other app um called uh keen
master
king master yeah keen master so there's
literally no excuse if you're out there
there's no [ __ ] excuse no no excuse
everyone has a phone
[ __ ] if you if you need music
you got screen record
ah so if you need to put music in your
[ __ ] just screen ready screen record
turn off the turn off the notifications
screen record that [ __ ] straight
through
rip the audio from that layer it on the
video
and you do all that on your phone and
upload it to youtube all on my phone wow
like i'm i'm old school bro even when i
rap i i got notebooks like i i like the
value of using my hands
like being hands-on i like all your own
[ __ ] yeah edit all my own [ __ ] i'll be
up all night edit on my [ __ ] and if i
need to do a voice recording i'll go in
my closet close the door record like
that what's up y'all got to interrupt
the bootleg cab podcast we have a brand
new sponsor
and i love this sponsor i've been giving
them my money for a long time it's about
time they gave some back my bookie yes
that's right
if you are a gambler if you're not a
gambler let me tell you my bookie is the
best place to go alright super bowl
season is here super bowl 56 is right
here and trust me my boogie's double
deposit bonus is something you don't
want to miss if you sign up at my
booking now use the promo code bootleg
that's b-o-o-t-l-e-g
to have your first deposit matched
instantly
up to a thousand dollars so if you put a
thousand in they'll match your thousand
dollars and you get in on all the action
for super bowl 56 i mean seriously
joe burrow vs matthew stafford the rams
are playing the super bowl at home in la
what does that even mean because none of
these home games i've been to them
it's a lot of out
outdoor fans coming in the 49ers took
that place over twice in the last month
we'll see how the bengals fans show up
all right this is the most important
game of the year it's the biggest game
of the year and you can get paid by
watching it my book is giving you
everything you need to do it with that
double your money you can double your
winnings and the best starting point for
the big game is these super bowl prop
bets they're fun
anybody can do these right
hey mom what color do you think the
gatorade is going to be to get spilled
at the end of the game hey what about
that toy the coin flip is it heads or is
it tails whatever it is is matthew
stafford going to throw a stupid ass
interception probably
probably
is joe mixon gonna score a touchdown i
like it i don't know get in on that prop
back action and uh listen even if you
don't pick on who's gonna win you you
could be a winner all right uh it's a
great look the prop bets are the most
fun for the super bowl so don't miss out
head to my bookie double your first
deposit up to a thousand dollars by
using the promo code bootleg
place your bets get ready for the
unmatched excitement for that super bowl
that is a thousand dollars in free money
that they will match so you deposit a
thousand they match a thousand bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
let's get back to the podcast it's crazy
because
a lot of people use the excuse well i
don't have cameras cameras are expensive
or
someone who can edit or i don't learn it
my macbook
does can't handle the footage
i don't have
man look if you're doing it all on your
phone
no excuse there's no excuse bro i'm
telling you you know how many times my
[ __ ] stories be so full in this phone
i got to delete everything out of my
phone pictures videos of like family
[ __ ] i'll be uploading to dropbox now
right but like
no excuse my phone didn't crash and then
blacked out because i edited so much and
i had too much footage but i believed in
myself that much that i'm not gonna give
myself an excuse not to be great i'm not
gonna say oh is this person fault i
don't have this i don't have that no you
built that [ __ ] up and then the team
comes as you build the thing about it is
you have to learn something in order to
uh to to to get somewhere you have to go
through those punches if you don't take
that hard route when you make it and
[ __ ] crumble you don't know how to pick
those pieces back up but once you learn
how to get it from where you are at
[ __ ] you straight and it's not just
like rich people when rich people lose
all their money i'm gonna kill myself
they don't know what to do because they
don't know how to get it once you know
how to get it you know you straight no
matter what happens it's a one-man army
over here come on that's big come on the
other thing too is consistency right
like i always tell people like if you
start something a lot of people get
discouraged because maybe the first two
or three four five even ten things they
do might not set the [ __ ] world on
fire but it's like yo
if you believe in yourself if it's good
it's got to be good yeah because there's
rappers who we know probably been
rapping for 20 [ __ ] years it's like
get up get ahead your [ __ ] is trash yeah
yeah real soon
but like if your [ __ ] is good if you're
dope if you're doing quality [ __ ]
whatever you're doing music content
whatever podcast as long as you're
consistent
it's gonna eventually it's gonna work
for you you just have to just
not get derailed by you know that [ __ ]
because like
it is discouraging
but you got to think about it
not everybody is going to like what you
do and there's going to be some people
that do so you do it for those like it's
better for you to do it from those core
fans that [ __ ] with you because you know
for a fact if i do a show if i do
anything these are the core people that
i know that's going to buy this i'm
going to purchase this so i need to
figure out a way to make sure they keep
coming back yeah you just take you just
keep doing your [ __ ] people they're
gonna pay your bills keep the lights on
come on don't sit there and think about
oh is it gonna [ __ ] with it no
work so hard to you putting [ __ ] out
you're not even what it's not even on
your mind cause you working so much and
then it's gonna cut to be like oh [ __ ]
all right mom i'mma keep mashing you
gotta keep going no matter what i didn't
i didn't fail with this [ __ ] i didn't
have breaks to where i had to stop i had
to like just just get my thoughts
together
but don't live in that you feel me like
take your time
but go for it and then stay consistent
on your [ __ ] a lot of things that people
don't understand is like
hard work does beat talent
this is the [ __ ] truth man like [ __ ]
if you work hard as [ __ ] you can get
somewhere it's it's a person that's
funnier than me that's in the hood the
only difference is bro you don't have
that that that passion that drive to
make it happen right right yeah i'm
saying it's like people that we know
that are trash
that of trash and not to disrespect
nobody but you know certain things are
trash and they make it because what they
work hard
no excuses like you got to have hard
work bro yeah no hard work beats talent
every every time man come on man i mean
we know so many i know so many of my
homies who are like amazing athletes and
could have been in the league yeah but
they didn't put the work in they didn't
take the [ __ ] serious they was [ __ ]
[ __ ] or they were partying or they
were doing all that i was like bro
eliminate that yeah [ __ ] now you're in
the drew league which is a nice place to
be like you should be in the league you
know what i mean
um what is what's next for you man um
everything under the sun um
movies tv shows um
what are you working on right now like
are you working on season two
of the show yep i'm working on season
two growing up in la um
i'm working on directing like a few um
commercials for pro club
um
i'm just really just tapping in
everything i'm i'm gonna record music um
i'm gonna work on like some animation
cartoons and [ __ ] like just
i'm i'm doing everything as long as i
got feeling in my hands and my legs i'm
doing it all bro um are you gonna
do the music thing from a serious
standpoint or are you gonna try to mix
in some of the comedy i'm gonna do um
i'm gonna do both i'm gonna do it from a
serious standpoint and i'm also gonna
give people what they like as far as me
because one thing i got an incredible
ear for creating those artist collabs or
who i want to hear on the song when i do
the celebrity impressions so i'm going
to give them that but i'm going to give
them
who i am you know as a music artist but
i'm not
doing it to use that to be in the
forefront i'm doing and putting it out
because i care about it so if you [ __ ]
with it you [ __ ] with it it's cool if
you don't i'm not tripping because i'm
doing it for me i'm not doing it for you
mm-hmm you know i'm saying so i'm gonna
just do everything that god put me on
this earth to do i feel like your videos
will be crazy thank you
thank you i feel like if you write
something
i'm just thinking like
nobody has done
and i'm not i'm not comparing you in
terms of like music or content but like
if you think of like
someone who's like comedically gifted
mm-hmm in their mind like little dickie
yeah who likes
fire his visuals yeah are literally what
broken because his videos were just so
good and so creative it's so funny yeah
like i feel like there's like a lane
where like
i mean obviously he's like a white
jewish guy and he's killed it yeah
dave's funny as [ __ ] yeah i feel like if
you kind of like did like your own
version of that but not like all the way
you know yeah goofy but like i feel like
your videos could be crazy no thank you
bro yeah i'm working on that um a person
that was was doing that in a sense was
uh i think it was like weird yakovich or
something oh weird out yeah weird yankee
[ __ ] yeah yeah he was doing that [ __ ]
when we were kids yeah and i was like
this dude is like funny as [ __ ] so like
platinum just remaking people [ __ ] like
um gangsters paradise all that [ __ ] is
paradise like so much said like i'm
gonna go crazy with some [ __ ] i had did
a few videos when i did um big bank
remix um i shot a video to that and i
did ygs in the dark
and i did like some other [ __ ] so i'm
gonna go crazy with the visuals and then
i'm gonna um figure out a way to like
mix it with like some animation [ __ ] to
give people like a dope ass feel what is
your
um take on like the national narrative
of la
anytime i'm listening to like certain
podcasts
they'll talk about well la's like it's
[ __ ] like the wild wild west right
now it's like grand theft auto right now
you got certain people in the la uh law
enforcement going on tv saying don't
come to la we can't protect you yeah um
the crime is up
what are your like like what's your take
on just kind of like the state of los
angeles right now i feel like
i feel like it's like a half and half
thing i feel like the city is like
hurting right now for whatever reason
we're hurting because it's a lot of like
senseless you know violence and
and crazy [ __ ] going on um
and the reasons can be all sorts of
things but i i'm like la is not that
shitty honestly like it has its bad
parts and it has bad moments but
you got so much talent out here you got
so much people that that [ __ ] with you
they be going to the wrong spots or
taking these movies and really like
mixing this [ __ ] up it ain't all that
bad like all day every day like it's
some cool [ __ ] today and a [ __ ] might
trip tomorrow and it's cool the next day
so it's just like
it's just like i feel like in a sense i
love my city but la is like kind of
bipolar
like it's bipolar that's the best way to
put it but it's it's not all bad as what
people try to make it seem to be it's
just certain areas you know you
shouldn't [ __ ] around with like get your
ass up out of there like you you can't
go there looking like a meal amongst a
group of [ __ ] that's hungry well i
think even in general like um
it's pretty like obvious right now that
like
if you're if you're walking in melrose
or you're certain areas like your [ __ ]
snatched so why the f if you're walking
over there wearing a [ __ ] patek
philippe or like yo what are you doing
like you're like just
yeah you know like you're asking like
you have to rob me yeah and then
[ __ ] are not doing this money
challenge yeah and it's like you're just
showing people you're [ __ ] moving
around with a lot of liquidity on you so
if they run into you oh yeah yeah what's
up with that what's up
you just had about 10 grand on your ig
spelling out some stupid [ __ ] phrase
where's that at you know what i'm come
on
yeah so i'm hearing too like like like
you know i was talking to somebody who
would know or at least you know um
semi know uh that a lot of those
robberies and [ __ ] low-key is a lot of
people who ain't him from la pulling
that [ __ ]
what
because you know like um
some of the [ __ ] that's going down is
[ __ ] up like um
homie's wife who got killed yeah
yeah um his name's skipping but i you
know i know a lot of people a lot of a
lot of the big homies that i know were
like actively trying to figure out who
did that because that was [ __ ] up yeah
and you know i don't think i think
some of the [ __ ] ain't even from people
from l.a it's just transplants out here
trying to get it in man yeah it's just i
just say just watch your ass
just yeah just move that's why anytime
an artist comes in here
and they're all iced out and they're
like yeah we're gonna go to boa tonight
or something i'm like hey look man don't
go yeah might wanna come on take all
that [ __ ] off come on man bro
y'all need to go back and learn about
chain snatching season chain snatching
season consists of award shows
uh what's that [ __ ] uh
memorial day weekend oh yeah all that
[ __ ] bro you getting your ass robbed
[ __ ] you can be out roscoe's and they
gonna get you you can be at the beverly
center like different
don't don't come out here on that [ __ ]
um
don't do that move humble move
respectful you can wear your changes in
your interviews and all that [ __ ] but
don't be
kicking it in the regular spots where
all it takes is that one person to see
you and then be like hey whoop up here
don't do that be smart we'll literally
tell everyone where they are on
instagram oh come on like
post post like take the video post it
two hours later
anymore yeah
it's just people just gotta move better
bro yeah that's crazy man well listen um
looking forward to the everything you
got going on
new season this year yeah this is for
sure yeah for sure um how often do you
post in a week on ig and on tick tock
instagram i post um every day so every
day there's a content yeah i'm back
assistant every day um i was slowing
down because i was writing the show and
doing a show now that i'm in the writing
process i still got wiggle room so what
i do is like the days i'm free i stock
up on hella content i shoot so much [ __ ]
and then start editing during the week
so i got stuff to post so every day tick
tock they keep deleting my [ __ ] so
yeah not that much but like youtube and
instagram every day shout out to youtube
man go how many how many subscribers
you're at now i got
212k on that road to 500k that's big
yeah yeah man that's money yeah it's a
nice check
man we know we're here yeah
yeah yeah shout out to youtube that
youtube money is good man we appreciate
you pulling up bro oh yeah also real
quick yeah
um
l.a is crazy right now um i'm i'm i'm
kind of black and i'm old like i got an
old soul this is my anointed blessing
oil so everybody if you're out in the
street get your blessing oil anoint
yourself head your chest the soles of
your feet the top of your head is to
allow
god to send his angels around you to
protect you and you just pray over
yourself because the city is going
through so much [ __ ] right now and i
feel like
it's not
safe like that what i'm saying so just
protect yourself stay out the way and
just whatever you believe in believe it
to the fullest where can someone buy
anointed blessing oil doesn't seem like
something you could just pull up to the
cornerstone well um
you can get like you can get some um
like olive oil and just pray over and
just anoint yourself or you can go to
like one of those small black churches
throughout the city and ask them that
that like you can't i mean well
some churches might say to some just
give it out because
it's it's of god so a lot of people
don't charge for it but um i'll let
y'all i'll let y'all know on my
instagram will you have
why told me quan anointed blessing oil
for sale on your ig yo no i can't sell
that oh i say hell no lord sorry sorry
no i can't sell that bro i can't sell it
but they move it you pull it out like
you're about to plug it you're like wait
wait but i just so listen two for ten
yeah only for the next 24 hours
i don't want to show people because like
they see me post god every day and i'm
just telling them like this this is me
every day like you see the bottle is
like almost gone i know it myself and
your skin is clear despite the fact that
you rub oil
you could have acne right now but it's
god's oil i'm saying so i anoint myself
and that's why i'm always protected
because i pray and anoint myself and i
move with respect that's amazing man
yeah we appreciate you pulling up bro
i'm a fan keep doing your thing watch
homie quan boom